teóricamente fuera de peligro y con un
visado humanitario polaco
la atleta bielorrusa cristina chamán
usca ya abandonó este miércoles los
juegos olímpicos en dirección al exilio
tras dos noches en la embajada de
polonia en japón antes de llegar a
varsovia ciudad que acoge varios
opositores de lukashenko
la corredora de 24 años hizo escala en
viena donde fue recibida por las
autoridades austríacas y por supuesto
está preocupada por su familia pero está
bien está cansada y triste por los
hechos de los últimos días pero como
decirlo estuvo bien posicionado
el trayecto de chamán osca ya iba a ser
directo desde tokio hasta varsovia pero
fue modificado por razones de seguridad
con el recuerdo todavía presente del
avión de ryanair que lukashenko desvío
en mayo para detener al opositor román
protosevich
durante los juegos la atleta crítico de
decisiones deportivas de su federación
en consecuencia el domingo dos miembros
del cuerpo técnico bielorruso la fueron
a buscar a la villa olímpica y la
llevaron al aeropuerto en un intento de
repatriación forzada del que escapó con
la ayuda de la policía japonesa y del
comité olímpico internacional que ha
anunciado una investigación formal de
fútbol y ver si su oficina para rally
white y hemos recibido un informe del
comité olímpico nacional que será
evaluado además el coi ha decidido abrir
una comisión disciplinaria para
esclarecer los hechos y para escuchar a
los dos oficiales
artur human y tour y hoy se dijo que
estarían implicados en este incidente
el incidente sucede un año después de
que estallara nuevamente con fuerza el
movimiento ciudadano contra lukashenko
mientras el régimen está cada vez más
aislado a nivel internacional